stuff and you send it back another thing
that happens a lot of people in certain
districts this is historically a lot of
people in certain districts don't ever
get their ballot they keep calling
where's my vote where's my ballot then
Election Day passes and they forget
about it and that can happen in the
thousands I'm not saying it does but I
can it probably has what could help
Michigan Michigan is a great state I've
gotten tremendous business to go to
Michigan
Michigan's one of the reasons I ran I
was honored in Michigan long before I
thought about I was honored as the man
of the year at Michigan at a big event
and I got up and I remember so well I
spoke probably five six years before I
even thought about running for president
and I got up and I spoke and I said why
are you allowing them to steal your car
business you know we lost 32 percent of
our car business to Mexico and a lot of
it came out of Michigan and I said why
did you allow that to happen and I posed
many questions to Michigan that not I
think I made it quite an impression and
now we have those same car factories
they're coming back except in a brand
new ER and bigger form so I think we're
going to do very well in Michigan I
guess we just got a poll that's very
good right here a very good poll about
how we're doing in Michigan and other
swing states and just generally in the
election but I won't show you I'm sure
you can get it I won't flip this over
everyone saying could you flip it over
but no I think we're doing very well in
Michigan very great place and I'll be
there tomorrow and I guess it's tomorrow
but I'll be there tomorrow the Ford
plant and maybe going to do the double
stop where I'll go back on the dams but
we have to take care of a problem
well nothing if you take New York in New
Jersey which were very hard head we were
very very low and in terms of morbidity
and in terms of you look at the death
relatively speaking we're at the lowest
level along with Germany and Germany us
it could have been some smaller
countries to perhaps I'd like to ask you
maybe about that if I could Deborah
we've done you know amazing well I I
think I think the biggest thing we did
is stopping the inflow from China
into our country and Deborah was a big
big supporter of that I mean in terms of
how important it turned out to be and so
was Tony foutch II they were very very
tony said we save thousands and
thousands of lives that was a great
decision that was made and that was made
very early pleased Deborah particularly
confusing to the American people we
don't emphasize the size of our country
we're the third largest country in the
world but every country has a different
experience with this virus and so you
have to adjust everything to population
size and so when you look at Spain and
Italy our attack rates to this virus are
identical to other countries that have
experienced the type of epidemic that we
have experienced and so every country is
different that's why you really need to
always report data normalized for
population and then you look at the
mortality by population and it's true we
have compared to our European colleagues
some of the lowest mortality about half
of Italy in Spain and so I think it's
really important that and in these two
states represent what we've been asking
states to do and Kansas they found 50
percent of their clusters were in
specific meatpacking nursing homes they
identified their clusters they found
their clusters they took care of those
clusters and that was 50 percent of all
of their cases and Arkansas 80 percent
of their the Arkansas individuals have
recovered with less than a 2 percent
mortality and so these are the it's
really important we're a big country
but each state is different but as a
country we're different than other
countries around the world we'll be
asking questions later about you know
why we're certain countries completely
spared and I think that's that's always
a question that we have epidemiology is
like that but if your country has never
had significant infections you can't
compare it to a global number there's
multiple countries in Africa where
there's really almost no outbreak and
then South Africa has a very different
outbreak so each of these outbreaks are
different and that's why it has to be
really granular to understand it and and
to respond to it and you can see these
two states have done exactly what we
asked them to do find cases contact
trace contain app breaks and ensure that
their citizens do as well as possible
and that's what these states illustrate
in just a finishing question I mean so
we're in that category along with
Germany as the lowest and I think that's
a great it's a great honor and that's
including New York and New Jersey which
have had a very they had a very high
number so if you include New York New
Jersey do everything if you don't
include New York and New Jersey were
just about in a class by ourselves now
with all of well China you tell me about
you think they're right numbers do you
think China's giving the right number I
don't think so I don't think so take a
look at the numbers they gave numbers
that was so low I mean I saw more
problem on television than they were
reporting just by looking at a picture
so I'm not including China and any
numbers because those numbers weren't
correct obviously that's been easily
shown and easily proven but no our
people have done a fantastic job Deborah
I always talk about the fact that our
testing is so far advanced that would
loss to 14 million in testing 14 million
and would you say China's at not China
if you would say Germany would be it
maybe three or four three and South
South Korea's and a number you tell us
what
numberous well we've been way ahead of
South Korea for a long time yeah
everybody Germany's done three million
tests Italy three million test UK about
2.7 million stain three million and I
think to us it's not just the number of
tests it's how those tests are utilized
and I think in both of these states you
can see they focused testing where they
knew the outbreaks were and now they're
proactively testing and nursing homes
where they think the outbreaks where our
could go next and finding the
asymptomatic cases I think we've just
we've only learned in the last couple of
months how many a symptomatic cases
there are and I think a lot of people at
the beginning wanted to approach this
like flu and you know most of the people
who get flu are symptomatic so really I
think our our our thoughts have evolved
our understanding has evolved and the
states have evolved with us really
working in partnership to really change
how we look for cases and I think that's
really remarkable we're not waiting for
people to get sick to find cases now and
you know what you're doing with testing
and what you're doing with testing in a
proactive way is the way we're moving as
a country and because we can do nearly
14 million tests we have the luxury to
be able to be proactive in our testing
now but when you do 14 million tests
you're going to find more cases if
instead of 14 million tests we did 3
million like Germany's at about 3
million South Korea's at 3 million and
they've done a very good job it's not a
knock but we're almost 14 million we're
gonna be passing 14 million very soon so
you're gonna have more tests if we do
three million everyone say oh we're
doing great you know in terms of cases
even have more cases if we get three
million maybe that's what we should have
done I see if I would have done three
minutes ago they have very few cases
United States is doing well we're
finding a lot of people by doing testing
you're finding people so we're doing 14
Germany's 23 South Korea to 3 and I
think they're number 2 & 3 so we're way
ahead of everybody but when you do that
you have more cases so a lot of times
the fake news media will say you know
there's a lot of cases in the United
States well
we didn't do testing at a level that
nobody's ever dreamt possible you
wouldn't have very many cases so we're
finding a lot of cases and we're doing a
great job once we find okay thank you
very much some of the European countries
are at four to five percent and I think
our goal is to ensure that we can find
the asymptomatic
and I think that's really our focus
right now working with every state to
really help them identify where these
clusters came from historically and then
proactively going for those clusters
identifying them early and finding the
asymptomatic individuals before and that
no one's intending to spread the virus
they always want to be very clear about
that
asymptomatic patient people don't know
they're infected and so together we're
really working to find them and I think
it's a it's a unique challenge and I
think together we're really making
progress and you know when you see a per
capita there's many perk a penis is like
per capita relative to what but you
could look at just about any category
and we're really at the top meaning
positive on a per capita basis - they've
done a great job please okay
no I wasn't complied or know who gave
you that just fake news yeah I do I do
as fake news Caitlyn fake news
therefore you can report it on CNN it's
perfect for CNN no not at all